we don't want to get too dark here but
the fact is we all have a limited time
in our lives so why not make the most of
it with a marathon of amazing ninja
movies pop some popcorn sharpen your
katana and come with us as we comb
through the good the bad and the
completely inexplicable to bring you the
best ninja movies you must see before
you die heroes of the east if you're
looking for a place to jump on with
ninja movies there aren't a lot of
better starting points than 1979's
heroes of the east also known as Shaolin
versus ninja it follows the time-tested
formula of hitting a master of one style
against a group of rivals to see whose
kung-fu reigned supreme in this case
that master is the legendary Gordon Liu
who was fresh off his breakthrough
performance as the hero of 36 chamber of
Shaolin and would go on to international
fame as pi may in Quentin Tarantino's
Kill Bill 5 element ninjas any
conversation about classic martial arts
movies usually leads to one of the most
widely accepted truisms of the genre
five deadly venoms rules hard the 1982
follow-up Five Element ninjas combines
everything good about that cult film and
takes it about five steps further over
the top while it's not as well-known as
its predecessor Five Element ninjas is
every bit the blood-soaked classic the
venoms is the plot is pretty simple a
kung-fu school that was defeated in
battle hires a color-coded element
themed ninja clan to get revenge on the
Warriors to beat them but honestly that
hardly matters when you're getting
glorious fight scenes with ninjas
appearing and disappearing and a cloud
of red smoke or watching the heroes
celebrate tearing their enemies in half
by punching a giant boulder so hard that
it explodes
[Music]
ninja 3 the domination if you want to
see the eighties ninja explosion in all
of its bizzare high-concept glory you
need to go straight to the third entry
in the infamous cannon films ninja
trilogy that's not to say into the ninja
and revenge of the ninja aren't worth
seeing because they definitely are now
wait wait ninja wait why don't we speak
like civilized men but the first two are
necessary to enjoy ninja 3 the
domination after the opening that binds
a ninja launching a wildly violent
assassination attempt on a golf course
the mysterious warrior ends up dead but
not before his soul possesses an
aerobics instructor who suddenly finds
herself unwillingly moonlighting as a
deadly assassin
it's twist on the usual ninja movie
setup that combines martial arts action
with the setup of a horror movie and the
end result is pure 80s madness American
ninja 2 the confrontation if you're only
going to watch one of canons American
ninja films and let's be real here
you should definitely only watch one the
second installment is by far the best
Michael Dudikoff returns as an Army
Ranger named Joe Armstrong who's
investigating the disappearances of a
handful of Marines from a military base
in a Caribbean paradise with a sidekick
Curtis Jackson it turns out those
abducted jarheads of being brainwashed
and genetically altered into an army of
super ninjas which means Armstrong and
Jackson have to ninja their way through
an entire base of brainwashed bad guys
to blow up the entire operation it's
goofy full of bloodless knockouts and
over-the-top twists but all of that adds
up to a movie that's a bra really
entertaining just make sure you don't
follow it up with the incomprehensible
American ninja 3 blood hunt pray for
death on one level pray for death is
basically just death wish with Charles
Bronson swapped out for shoka Sookie
look a little deeper though and there's
something in here that's a little bit
smarter than your average ninja revenge
story make no mistake there is a lot of
ninja revenge in this movie with kosugi
playing the role of Akira a highly
trained ninja who leaves his life of
violence behind in order to travel
to America with his family and open a
restaurant like pretty much all of
Kazuki's ninja films the action is
spectacular
but the really compelling stuff here
comes in how the movie presented Keira
as an immigrant in pursuit of a peaceful
new life in America and the contrast
between the dream of success and the
barriers he encounters along the way
Ninja Assassin on the off chance that
you were worried joke Kosugi had stopped
being a total badass after the 80s don't
fret in 2009 his starring role was the
villain of ninja assasin prove that he
definitely still had it produced by the
Wachowskis and directed by james McTighe
ninja assassin cass Kousuke as lord
ozuna they're ruthless head of a ninja
clan that trains orphans from birth to
become killer ninjas
unfortunately for Osuna his chosen
successor
raizou goes renegade setting the stage
for exactly the kind of beautiful
visually stunning fight scenes that you
expect from people who brought you the
matrix the Octagon if you only ever
watch one Chuck Norris movie in your
life well it should be lone wolf McQuade
if only because Chuck Norris drives a
pickup truck out of his own grave
if you want to go with one with ninjas
however you've got to go for the Octagon
despite the lack of truck based
resurrection it's basically a perfect
storm of a Chuck Norris movie Norris
stars is Scott James who finds himself
caught up in a terrorist plot since he
just happens to be pals with a couple of
mercenaries who are also dealing with
the severe ninja problem the whole thing
climaxes in a sequence where Scott James
has to fight his way through the ninjas
own lair the Octagon assuming director
vu hey kitty Mura is probably best known
for his work on godzilla final wars but
if you really want to see Kitamura take
on hyper-violent widespread destruction
you need to sit down and watch Azumi
based on the manga of the same name
assuming offers incredibly stylish
action with practical effects enhanced
by cgi that only rarely ends up feeling
silly and there's a twist at the end
that's truly delightful for fans of
ninja action ESO Takashi Miike his
career as a director has been all over
the map but the one thing that unites
all of his films is a style that urges
on the surreal creating movies that are
often less about the narrative and more
about the experience that's the case
with ESO which follows a 19th century
assassin through the afterlife
punctuating violent encounters with big
questions about the nature of suffering
it's certainly not the fun martial arts
romp that you'll get with other films
but it's definitely fascinating and
worth a watch for the ninja obsessed
Miami connection made with a miniscule
budget in 1987 by amateur filmmaker
martial artist and Dragon sound
rhythm guitarist YK Kim Miami connection
received incredibly poor reviews on its
initial release but became an instant
cult classic after it was unearthed by
the Alamo Drafthouse in 2012 it's easy
to see why to the tortured drama
energetic amateur acting and
spectacularly weird plot of a synth-pop
band martial artist throwing down
against a bunch of cocaine dealing ninja
bikers all add up to an incredible
amount of weird charm that more than
makes up for what this movie lacks in
technique
watch it or suffer the wrath of this guy
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]